c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
mais c'est quoi ce truc on dirait une
plante un parasol qui a mal terminé
un corail honnêtement vous voulez que je
vous dise que c'est c'est le type en une
île du sable une vague de l'art
contemporain le lac d'eau un artichaut
la petite sirène de copenhague sur le
rocher comme ça c'est aussi l'indonésie
voilà avec sumatra en bas mais
franchement c'est une grippe qui pendant
des heures
tortue très bon ça ressemble un peu à la
bête de l'histoire sans fin la qui me
faisait peur peur peur d'un style le mur
n
c'est un poisson non pour un sou
[Musique]
non mais vous aussi vous amuser vous
avisez bon je voyais que c'était dans
l'eau mais je voyais pas du tout comme
ça n'existe pas ça cette fois-ci règne
au qu'il est beau un poisson en poissons
[Musique]